welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with 1917 now
making its way worldwide I thought it
was time to talk about what is one of my
favorite movies of the air 1917 doesn't
need an ending explained the events of
the movie are pretty straightforward the
finale won't leave you asking any
questions and everything ties up in a
way that services the entire story
however that doesn't mean that the
ending isn't worth talking about and
this film finalizes on a beautifully
somber moment that has stuck with me
long after seeing the movie throughout
this video we're gonna be breaking down
the journey that the characters in the
film go on as well as the real-life
events that inspired them there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to see 1917 yet and don't
want to know what happens then I highly
suggest that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for click in this video now let's
get into why the ending of 1917 is so
perfect
[Applause]
19:17 is filmed as one continuous shot
the camera doesn't cut away at any point
there's no mid scene changes no
diverting from what's happening on
screen and because of this the film
feels relentless shooting an entire
movie in this style is an extremely
difficult task but a director Sam Mendes
purposely put this in place as it's
necessary for the film's overall message
there are no real breaks in war no real
moments of respite no moments to mourn
are taken what's really going on and
what you've sacrificed in order to fight
for Queen and country
one moment you'll be clasping at your
best friend as they pass away and the
next you'll be selling to a song sung by
a soldier you really don't have a chance
to take it in or truly comprehend
exactly what's happening every single
second could be a last no matter whether
you know her or not and because of this
it helps the audience who not only
engage with the journey early on but
also to be invested in it as it takes
its cause throughout the almost two-hour
run time we open on a shot the field
that is almost instantly juxtaposed by
two soldiers perfectly it sets at the
dichotomy of the film in which we will
see our central characters go on a
journey through hell all while
surrounded by the natural beauty of the
world these two characters are corporals
Scofield and Blake both of whom have
been given a task of the utmost
importance under orders they are to
cross into former German territory to
deliver a message to Colonel McKenzie a
soldier that is currently chasing after
the retreating German forces this is a
trap the Germans are willingly
withdrawing in order to lure the British
army into a situation where they can be
ambushed and wiped out the two have been
chosen because Blake's brother is in the
bridge Brigade about to be slaughtered
and they set off immediately the movie
itself is actually based on the true
story of the directors grandfather
alfred Mendez who served in the British
Army during the war Sam Mendes was told
stories by his grandfather what it was
like to be in the conflict and from this
he put the movie together I'm sure many
of you at home watching
it's similar tales growing up and even
today the first world war still looms
massively of the united kingdom my own
great-grandfather was a sergeant major
during the war and often my grandmother
would recount to me tales of his bravery
and also the horrors that he faced every
day Mendez's grandfather was awarded
with a medal for bravery after he
volunteered on a mission to locate
injured soldiers in no-man's land
George McKay who stars as the film's
main lead also relates heavily to the
movie as his great-great uncle Albert
Victor Bork was also tasked with a
similar mission to what we see play out
Bork was a signaler for the 196 each
battery in France and he helped to relay
important messages across land as we see
McKay's character do in the film it's
stories like this that grant the movie
with a feeling of authenticity and you
can see the personal tales shape the
facets of the movie grounding their
massively as Blake and Schofield make
their way across the landscape there are
a huge range of emotions portrayed in
just a few minutes one second there
gingerly approaching what may or may not
be an abandoned outpost the next they're
laughing about life in the trenches all
before climaxes in the death of Blake
who was murdered by a German pilot that
crash lands close to them Blake bleeds
out and Schofield promises him that he
will write to his mother and say that he
wasn't scared just like that
Schofield has watched his friend die in
front of him the worst thing that could
happen has but there's no chance to
mourn his friend no moment to sit and
collect his thoughts more soldiers
arrive and tell him not to dwell on the
loss of Blake and us all of this pain
all of this agony that Schofield is
going through it's brushed to the side
and Duty is put before death it really
exemplifies to stiff-upper-lip that
Britt's a stereotyped is having and
betrays how when things are at the
lowest we often don't have time to even
accept that they are the way that they
are and we must keep moving Schofield
himself isn't really even that happy
that he's a soldier he takes no joy in
war and even confesses to Blake that the
prior medal he received he ended up
exchanging for wine he just doesn't want
to remember any of this
but he stuck in an impossible situation
doing the best that he can
there are dark humor moments such as
when he accidentally puts his hand in a
corpse on the battlefield and a real
feeling of kinship but ultimately every
soldier in this war wants to get home
get away from it and be back with the
ones that they love this is exemplified
early on in the movies introduction when
Blake says he hopes to be home before
Christmas and it solidifies where the
real sense of duty for these men is they
were fighting in order to protect the
ones that they love back home fighting
in these hellscape so that the ones that
they cared about didn't have to
experience what they did Schofield
continues to make the journey himself
dodging gunfire watching towns burned to
the ground and eventually he comes
across a French woman named Laurie and
her baby
Laurie tends to his wounds but in
retrospect this setup is similar to the
one that Scofield left behind the film
ends with the character looking at a
photo of his wife and children and
seeing this firsthand really backs up
the prior point that these men were
fighting so that women and children
wouldn't have to go through the horrors
of war firsthand Laurie begs him to stay
and he easily could at one point he even
looks like he will but an ominous church
bell rings and reminds him that he's
against the clock there are more
important things out there he breaks out
jumps into a river and flows upstream
finally breaking upon reaching the shore
watching the character cry is agonizing
and it reminds you that throughout all
of the film we haven't really had a
chance to even catch our breaths and
take in exactly what has gone on one
shot takes often leave you feeling like
you don't have a moment to breathe and
seeing the character go through this is
one of the most impactful moments of the
film Schofield arrives too late and the
battle begins with the first wave being
sent out the trenches are full and nuts
in order to stop the rest of the waves
going forward Schofield takes a shortcut
by running sideways across the
battlefield
it's an insane moment that is incredible
to see play out on the big screen and is
one that I'm sure will stick in many
people's memories after watching the
movie finally he reaches Colonel
Mackenzie played by Benedict Cumberbatch
who after reading the letter or as his
men to stand down looking for Blake's
brother Schofield goes to the medical
tent and comes face to face with him
played by Richard Madden Schofield tells
him of his siblings fate and gives him
some of his
that he took from him upon his death
Blake is naturally ripped apart by the
news it's a crushing blow to him but as
we discussed there is no real time to
mourn here and he pulls himself together
almost instantly all of the men who
fought in this war have been forever
changed by the events that they saw the
journey that they went through and know
they may have made it through the war
the ending does not matter this took
away the humanity but it doesn't mean
that they have lost it forever the film
ends with Schofield and Blake shaking
hands and what is the world war one
equivalent of an emotional hug Schofield
promises to write Blake's mother and he
goes to sit under a tree similar to how
he first met him in the opening however
this time he is without Blake he is a
man who has had a friend torn away from
him because of the journey that we've
seen him go through he pulls out a photo
of his wife and children and looks at
them reminding himself of what he has
waiting for him when he gets home the
hope that if he makes it out of the war
he may get to see them again every day
he is fighting to make it just one more
he will likely go through more journeys
similar to this faced death every day
but one day it will end and he will be
reunited with the family that he's
fighting to protect every moment that
he's gone through every agonizing
footstep that he's taken forward has
been in order to get to this one
solitary second in which he can remind
himself of his family he turns over a
photo that says come back to us and
closes his eyes which ends the film it
really is the perfect way to close the
movie off reminding us that no matter
what we go through there's always the
hope that things can get better and that
somewhere out there is a day that will
make it all worth it
19:17 is not only a technical
masterpiece but a masterpiece of
storytelling as well the film is an
incredible feat that has its heart in
the right place and now I went into the
movie expecting it just to be another
by-the-numbers war story it told me far
more about the human condition
Brotherhood death family and how through
it all we must keep moving even when we
are at our lowest 1917 was incredible
and that's why it scores a 10
10 now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on 1917 and if you agree with
me or not comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out our breakdown of last
week's big release The Grudge which
should be linked at the end we go over
the entire movies timeline and how it
ties in with the original so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to come
chat to me after the video that make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which you'll be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully
we see over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of Joker which
is one of our favorite movies of the
last year and all you have to do to be
in with a chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on 19:17
in the comments section below the
winners gonna be chosen at random on the
15th of January and the set will be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time take care peace
you
[Music]